- The president has been in
office barely three weeks.
Why can't you guys in
the media and Hollywood
give him some slack?
BILL MAHER: Because of
what he's done and said.
[interposing voices]
- [inaudible] only three weeks.
BILL MAHER: Three weeks?
- Give him a break.
Can't you give him a break?
BILL MAHER: Give him a break?
Do you read the news?
Do you--
- --which is the
toughest job on earth?
BILL MAHER: The
toughest job on earth
has never been done like this.
First of all, this is beyond
the realm of politics.
If you're just talking
about politics--
OK, let's pretend that
it's just politics.
I would have big problems
there, because it's a giant con,
what he's done.
He ran for the little man.
And then what does he do?
He gets into office.
The coal companies can
dump sludge in the river,
because you know, that's what
the little man is aching for.
Undoing Dodd-Frank, because
so many of the town halls
in Appalachia, people were
standing up and saying,
Mr. Trump, please get
rid of the Volcker Rule.
Because if I can't make certain
speculative investments,
it's killing us here.
So that's just the
political part.
We could have a normal
conversation about that.
But this presidency is not
about the political part,
even three weeks in.
It's beyond politics.
It's about sanity.
It's about somebody who makes
stuff up, who doesn't read.
His information is
either anecdotal
or pulled right out of his--
what word, Reverend, should I--
his behind.
Of course, we're worried
when the president
sees multitudes
that don't exist,
as in the illegal voting--
3 million.
That should bother you.